this is the face of Peter before they
subscribe to the new world review
noticeably grumpy unsatisfied with life
and filled with nothing but our to
despair meanwhile this is the face of
Pete Oh after they subscribe to the New
York you elated and full of life because
they now receive regular hunt onto
content uploaded straight into their
YouTube feed and it's just amazing what
a difference one little button can make
she is someone precious to a person I
care about deeply if you so desire I'll
break my right arm as well if that's not
enough then I offer both of my legs if
you think I won't keep my promise after
I heal her then you can mangle my body
as long as it doesn't hinder the
treatment I beg you let me do this
please let me save her hello and welcome
to hunt hunter 101 the series that
breaks down everyone and everything in
the Hunter hunter world and today we are
going to examine the first pawn of the
chimera and King's Royal Guards NetHope
toe NetHope toe is a very playful
chimera and sporting the appearance of a
humanoid cat and just get this right out
of the way at the beginning there is a
great deal of gender ambiguity when it
comes to Peto because in the manga Peto
is drawn very much as a young male
whilst in the anime they elected to give
Peto a more feminine presence as well as
a consistent bust the only real
indicator we have comes from the
official dada book which states that
peter uses pronouns such as cada &
beaucoup the first of which meaning he
and the second of which is a common male
way of saying i would that said book can
also be used by women although it is
much less common but there is a lot of
evidence to suggest that Takashi
purposely implemented this ambiguity so
this video is going to have to stick to
gender-neutral pronouns just for the
sake of ease
cool so in any case Beto is quite the
unique member of the Royal Guards
intends to show a lot more personality
than their counterparts or even that of
the king himself Beto is generally seen
as cheerful wild the curious and easily
carried away when having fun but don't
let that lull you into a false sense of
security because this cheerful kittycat
also has an incredibly cruel and
sadistic nature thriving on the brush of
battle and taking great pleasure from
the act of killing in general with that
said Peter was also exceptionally loyal
to the ant King Mara web and does not
let these desires interfere with their
duty as a chimera ant in fact an
argument can even be made the peep-toe
is in fact the most loyal of the three
world guards as they were the only one
to remain completely unfazed by the
Kings interest in a certain girl by the
name of kimochi where they just sort of
went with the flow
fulfilling Mara whims needs and desires
as they arose rather than questioning
them but as
first world card born Neff Peter was
named directly by the chimera ant queen
and PTO's powerful presence was
immediately felt by the rest of the
colony and moving forward immediately
PTO's terrifying aura was able to
command the generally rambunctious
Vermont into immediate submission which
was an impressive feat at the time and
as a result Peter took it upon
themselves to commandeer leadership of
the colony for the time being however
Peter was also overcome with the desire
to test their abilities and so sought
out Kate gone and Kilwa after sensing an
activation of N and here PTO's monstrous
strength would be immediately displayed
as they managed to rip kites arm clean
off and just to be clear
kite is no pushover he was The
Apprentice of the infamous Santa Jing
and possessed his own incredible
strength speed and mastery of nen that
had been completely unrivaled by a
chimera and opponent prior to this point
however Peter proceeded to fight and
kill kite as if he were absolutely
nothing that is the insane existence
that is never Peter born with
extraordinary power as well as a natural
mastery of aura nodes allowing Peter to
immediately access the art of nen and
one of their most notable features is
the power to produce an incredibly
overwhelming and fear inducing
invocation of ten now just to clarify I
am NOT referring to Ren which is your
typical offensive expression of aura
sometimes resulting in the blood loss
phenomenon no in this case Peter was
able to replicate a similar result using
just a standard 10 and Peter was also
able to produce a rather staggering n
which takes the form of a vast array of
manipulatable tendrils rather than a
typical sphere each of which is capable
of extending a maximum of two kilometres
making Peto effectively the ultimate
guard cat but delving a bit deeper Peto
has the distinction of being classified
as a specialist most terrifying class of
nen user because they aren't boxed in by
regular restrictions and can very
effectively wield their aura in a more
personal manner and speaking of with
their vast quantities of aura Vito went
on to create a slew of unique Otsu that
reflected their desires the first of
which is a creepy conjurer presence
known as dr. blithe a giant doll like
bingo that comes equipped with a supreme
array of medicinal tools allowing it to
treat fatal wounds and even reconstruct
corpses in fact dr. Blythe was created
to repeat OHS desire to face off against
kite once more and peter was able to
achieve that to some degree of success I
guess but there are a couple of caveats
in regards to dr. Blythe the first of
which being that this supposed men beast
cannot move from a particular spot once
summoned as well as the fact that it is
directly connected to PTO's tail thus
resulting in a severe loss of mobility
for
putting them in a greatly vulnerable
position whilst administering any
healing well it's worse though is that
having talked to quite active prevents
Peter from using any other ninh
abilities including basic and advanced
principles such as n although a small
amount of aura is left around Peto in
order to provide basic protection in any
case those deep limitations do result in
being capable of phenomenal medical
power but Vito has also developed an
effective offensive heart soon known as
top-scorer an M presence that takes the
form of a ballerina with strings on
fingertips connected to Peters body as
if Tubbs Cora was wielding a marionette
and the effects of having this heart too
active appears to be a general boost in
the physical capabilities of Peter by
having Tubbs Cora manipulate their body
beyond PTO's natural limits and further
wall Peter also has a basic ability
known as puppeteering by which Peter
creates a clown puppeteer thingy and can
then attach it to the corpse of a target
thus allowing them to manipulate it and
rather scarily if the body belonged to
that of an end user then Peter can also
command their new puppet to engage in
and related abilities and with all of
this in mind
Peter proved to be instrumental in
regards to marijuana plan of gathering
the citizens of East quarto to conduct
his brutal selection process which was
mainly achieved through Peter
manipulating the corpse of the nation's
previous figurehead however Peters
primary duty during the time taken to
gather the citizens was to use their
absurd and to act as a lookout and it
would be during said duty that one night
Peter would look up to find a nen dragon
gunning straight towards the palace an
unusual sight to say the least but soon
enough Peter came into contact with one
Isaac Metro the leader of an
extermination team dispatched to deal
with the threat of the chimera ants and
excited by the prospect of battle Peter
launched straight towards him only to be
swatted away like a fly
as a result Peter was left only capable
of witnessing the destruction of the
palace and by the time they reached King
Peter discovered marijuana cradling the
human Kaimuki who had been fatally
wounded in the attack Peter was then
ordered to heal committee with doctor
Blythe as Mara we're headed off to fight
his invaders however this put Peter in a
very vulnerable position where they were
found by gone and gone entire mission
during this extermination was to revive
kite whose death he felt responsible for
and he demanded the Peter go with him to
do exactly that veto then did something
very very out of character and pleaded
with gone to let them finish saving
Kaimuki first even going so far as to
break their arm as a sign of good faith
and in the face of this and enraged GaN
would eventually acquiesce to this
request and after Co Magee was healed
she would be take
hostage forcing Peter to be at the sheer
mercy of gone a being that Peter could
have easily eviscerated under normal
circumstances the pair then traveled to
the location of kites reanimated corpse
after which Peter declared that not even
their ability could bring kite back from
the dead Peter then genuinely apologized
to gone and prepared to kill him
however full of Rage despair sorrow and
all of that good stuff gone then made a
very very dangerous vow allowing him to
access a tremendous amount of aura which
transformed him into an adult version of
himself with power comparable to that of
the Chimera ant king himself Peter was
then forced into combat and brutally
beaten to death by gone however just
prior to Peters passing they came to
realize the extreme price that God had
paid for this immense Torah and rejoiced
because they were the target of this
rage rather than king marijuana and you
know you'd think that that might be the
end of it but after passing away PTO's
top-score hatsue became an indication of
post-mortem nen spawning from the
feelings of pure loyalty and devotion to
the king and thus it reactivated to take
control of Peter's lifeless corpse and
even managed to sever one of God's arms
although it was ultimately defeated once
more and to add insult to injury don't
even use the very same arm that
top-scorer severed to put it down for
good
thus bringing an end to Nephi Peters
legacy on this world small fun facts
banter for Peter Nephi Beto's name comes
directly from the Egyptian gardener fat
M as well as a character named Fito
from a French children's book called
Caroline it says a me which I've
probably butchered because my skills in
French followed the non-existent but
Neff at M in particular is notable
because the depiction of this card often
shows them with the head of a lion or a
cat thus very much reflecting Peters
design Peters hearts who doctor Blythe
takes both its name and visual
inspiration from a fashion doll known
simply as Blythe a brand that was first
created in the early 1970s and to this
day
Blythe dolls can still be found being
made by hasbro according to the hunter
hunter manual Peto scores a perfect 5
out of 5 in every area except for the
mind which they score a less than
perfect 4 out of 5 which is more than
likely due to how easily peter can
become distracted having secured an
incredible sixth place in the 3rd hunter
hunter character popularity poll NetHope
Joe actually has the distinction of
serving as the most popular chimera ant
in the series however it should be noted
that this poll was published in 2004
which did occur before the introduction
of marijuana would appear in 2005
however no other chimera ant at this
point in the series including the two
other members of the Royal Guard even
managed to
in the top 30 and finally a truly
useless fact NetHope toe is rather sadly
the only royal guard who never got to
learn maro Em's name but that pretty
much does it for NetHope toe if you
enjoyed this video in the content this
channel produce in general then please
do consider donating to the new world
view patreon because the support of all
of you amazing people is what continues
to make this channel possible and if
patreon isn't quite your style the
police would leave this video a like
share or subscribe because it also helps
sports channel an incredible amount and
if you'd like to join the fun at any
time then please do head over to my
discord server where a wide array of
Shannara takes place on a daily basis
and finally please do comment with who
what or where you'd like to see featured
on the next hunter hunter
101
tips on getting a waifu hmm so I guess
start watching any given enemy series
until you uncontrollably start
developing feelings for a 2d character
that's my understanding of it anyway
now whether if you're interested in
exploring the world of some sort of
real-life waifu well then things they
get a bit more complicated I would say
just make an effort to socialise like a
lot because the more people you meet the
higher the odds of finding someone that
you actually click with once that occurs
ask that person out see if you both want
to pursue if they say yes cool go on a
date see if you want to pursue some sort
of relationship and help Everlong down
the track if you want to get married and
ask them that as well and if they say
yes well then you have secured a
real-life waifu well husband oh but if
you prefer
Takashi jokingly stated everyone will
die when asked about how fun to hunter
will end what are your thoughts on this
statement alright so just to clarify
Takashi did indeed say this but it was
in reference to Korra pika and the
Phantom troupe specifically and yes it's
entirely possible that it was a jerk
I mean imagine that you as an author are
asked to answer a stupid question like
oh how does the series end because after
a while I guess you might be pretty
tempted to just give a troll answer
however because it's impossible to gauge
Takashi's turn from the written word I
kind of have no choice but to believe it
especially in the case of crop Rika
because he has roughly like a billion
death flag circling him in the manga and
the Phantom troupe have also put
themselves on very destructive paths I
mean two of them have already been
dispatched by a bigger more better aji
Sokka and the rest of them are now split
up into small groups both black well one
to search for him which is a marvelous
idea because you're just dividing your
power and making it easier to him to
pick you off one by one so at the moment
I am definitely inclined to believe
Takashi statement even if he was
trolling actually but it is important to
know that he was only referring to
karappa and the Phantom true